well I I know I didn't call this so
venom opened really well it opened with
an eighty million dollar opening weekend
I think it had the biggest it definitely
had the biggest preview night in October
in history which do that's the Thursday
showing I'm pretty sure it's all it's
also the biggest October opening weekend
overall they broke that record it did
about eighty million dollars in the US
about a hundred twenty international
which means it's already made two
hundred million dollars its original
budget was one hundred million which
means it's already broken even so
whatever it makes after this is is
profit or at least as far as anybody's
concerned because actual production
numbers are iffy because they don't
factor in marketing costs and all that
stuff but this this is a hit this is a
bonafide hit so what does this mean for
the future of Sony's plans in terms of
what have they talked about that they
want to do
spider-man related properties well the
most immediate sense you can definitely
count on the fact that we are going to
get a sequel to venom which is good
because they very blatantly set up a
sequel to venom in the mid-credits
trailer teaser at the end of venom so I
am gonna talk about that
I think world probably got out on what
that was but if you want to avoid that I
you might need to turn the video off
because I'm gonna be leaping off from
that at least for a decent stretch of
time so that mid-credits scene did set
up
cletus kasady being played by Woody
Harrelson in like a Ronald McDonald wig
and who will be carnage now the way that
carnage will manifest not yet entirely
clear as as far as whether it will
actually be a seed from venom
himself or if it'll just be another
symbiote I think it should be a seed
from venom because I think venom needs
that as that element of guilt that sense
that he helped create this thing that's
a big part of the dynamic and I think it
was it was a little bit of a gambit for
them to both hold off and blatantly set
up carnage but I think it was also the
right call in a little bit in a bit like
it was a really smart call that Batman
Begins didn't use the Joker and instead
set it up for the next one so that he
can so basically the Joker could good
bat cleanup in in the Dark Knight and
it's a similar thing with cars because
when you think about venom and venom as
enemies who's who's he gonna fight well
number one would be spider-man but
that's just not happening and then
number two is carnage so that's that's
now been that's been set up again we
don't know how carnage is gonna end up
with a symbiote here's the worrying
thing right now producer Avi Arad who
has been producer on the spider-man
related property since the Sam Raimi
movies and who has been trying to get
venom made for a long time I'm sure he
feels vindicated as heck with this box
office take he has indicated that it
should not be taken as a given that
including carnage means that the sequel
gets r-rated now coming back to what I
said before in my review of venom you
could really tell what had been cut down
you could tell that there that a lot of
they cut away from so many you know
venom bites a guy's head off or you know
they're people thrown into walls were
like his head cracked like there should
be blood splatter there and things like
that
that's all toned down for pg-13 and they
got away with it for the most part I
mean like I said you can tell but I
think structurally the fundamentals of
the film still work even the you know as
work as they work as well as
what happen are and as a pg-13 carnage
carnage is whole deal is it's not just
massive body count
it's brutal massive body count like that
that's his whole thing he is insane
before he gets assembiy it so like him
being a complete over-the-top massacre
machine it's kind of the point of it and
I don't know how you tone that down and
and still have the character feel like
carnage like I mean from a practical
standpoint they can do basically what
they did with with the first venom movie
which is you know to cut away and not
have a lot of actual blood not do
arterial spray or or what-have-you but
and that just what with doing that with
carnage would feel like even more of a
cop-out than doing it with a venom so
yeah I don't I I actually would have
heard much I don't think there was quite
the fan backlash to the final result of
the film being pg-13 instead of what a
lot of people had felt was originally
promised to be in our rated movie I
don't think there has been as much
backlash as I would have expected about
that but I do think at the very least
from fans that if they hear carnage is
gonna be in a pg-13 they're gonna get
real squirrely about that now that said
I did put the emphasis on fans because
you know mainstream people probably
won't really care so the the venom
sequel that's absolutely happening the
as far as the other spin-off stuff
that's been announced goes the one the
that is the most likely to come next
because it actually has a lead cast
would be the Morbius movie Morbius the
living vampire and that would be Jared
Leto now there is something very odd
that I noticed about the venom movie
which is
now my knowledge of venom is based on
when I read his stuff which was in the
90s so I don't know if this sort of
thing got integrated later on at least
when I was reading venom he didn't have
to eat people sometimes whatever at the
very least he would frequently threaten
to and I think maybe once or twice he
did but at least when I was reading
venom he the suit did not have to be fed
whereas in the movie sort of the deal is
if the suit doesn't eat for too long it
basically starts cannibalizing Eddie and
then edium makes the deal with it you
know if you're gonna eat people you can
only eat bad people now the reason I
bring that up is because that whole
struggle and final conclusion that's
Morbius is deal I mean venom you know
venom held the title of lethal protector
for a reason he did tend to kill people
but it wasn't because the suit needed to
feed it was because he was a violent guy
who did excessively violent means to try
and solve things and be a hero so having
him comes as if I must feed let it be on
the blood of those who would attack the
innocent or whatever like that's Morbius
his entire stick so I say Morbius is
most likely to come out next again
because it has a star attached to it
already
it'll be it runs the risk of being
incredibly redundant because they kind
of jacked
Morbius --is deal and gave it to venom
so I don't know how well that's going to
that's gonna play out or how potentially
derivative that could feel as far as the
release of these things Sony would do
well to insert something else between
you know either this first venom movie
between a venom movie and Morbius
whether it's this one or the sequel
they are really gonna want to get
something else in the middle there so
that it doesn't just look like they are
using the exact same narrative template
and stamping it on to these various
characters I mean granted this is the
template because of the that is actually
what Morbius is in the comics but again
they kind of ape tit already with this
first carnage film so some of the other
stuff you know it's it's tougher to call
so in terms of what's been announced
there's the silver sable movie there's
the black cat movie there's the jackpot
movie what and supposedly still the the
sinister six now I would say of those
the one I would say either silver sable
or Catwoman will be the next most likely
just because odds are those are going to
be lower budgeted Affairs probably not
as special effects heavy easier to put
together in a not too expensive and
timely fashion whereas oh and the Kraven
the hunters and career in the hunter
movie I forgot about that but certainly
something like jackpot or even Kraven
the hunter you know requires more
elaborate action stuff then you are
required to do a silver sable and black
cat not to save this silver sable or
black cat aren't very capable in action
scenes they are but they're certainly
with black cat the concept does not
require that level of expensive action
especially because in both cases they're
just they're just people they're just
women who are good at you know what they
do but they you know we're not dealing
with the expense of your big CGI monster
things with with any of that
so you know I think one of those is more
likely whereas if you do jackpot you're
looking at some comparable expenses to
at least the lower tier Spider Man movie
because she's got you know Jesus all
swinging around and so you need to be
prepared for those kinds of action
scenes probably gonna
CGI double her for a whole bunch of
stuff so yeah I would say most likely
after the and I would say again ideally
before but I'm not counting on it
the the Morbius movie would be either
the silver sable or the black cap movie
flip a coin could be either one but yeah
then after that there's sinister six
there is Craven there's jackpot and
there's probably other stuff percolating
as well that they just haven't announced
yet sinister six for my money they hold
that off because I bet you that they
want to try and tie directly into the
spider-man movies so that might involve
closer negotiations with say Marvel cuz
right now Marvel is absolutely free to
completely ignore the venom film which
is why you know Tom Holland did not
cameo in it and there aren't any
explicit connections to these system see
you in that movie because right now
Marvel is struggiing going you look you
go do your own thing but it's not part
of our thing we're at Sony's going maybe
it will be one day you never know which
is they're hopeful wishing that they are
so successful that Marvel will want to
integrate this thing that they've done I
actually don't think that's a good idea
at this point I don't think it's gonna
be a good idea to take this venom and
have him face off against spider-man
because I don't know how you build that
motivation because historically the
hatred that Eddie Brock has for
spider-man is all prior to him getting
the suit becoming venom and aside from
just I don't know Peter Parker takes a
trip to San Francisco for some reason
and just gets up a scrap with him like I
don't know how you how you get them at
odds because they're no they're
geographically nowhere near each other
and you know with with venom and then
the thing is even if like spider-man
came in and like captured him and
arrested him or whatever that wouldn't
justify the level of hatred that we are
used to seeing and he have towards Peter
so at this point with how they manage to
establish venom as a standalone I
character and franchise I don't think
he's actually gonna cross over well with
spider-man because I don't know how you
build the motivation that is really key
the you know motivating his hatred which
is so absolutely key to this entire
dynamic and relationship so I have no
doubt Sony would love would love to make
an event of a confirm part of the MCU I
don't think it should happen I don't
really see it happening but sinister six
I wouldn't be shocked if they're trying
to keep that a little bit tighter in
with with Marvel but again we'll see I
would expect if they move forward on the
sinister six movie it's going to include
some of the characters we've already
seen feasibly the vulture I would say
almost definitely the Scorpion possibly
the Mysterio who's you know gotta
apparently gotta be introduced in the
next one so you know who knows but one
thing I can tell you is there's no
question we're getting a venom sequel
and I think even if that does decent but
not great we get at least one other
thing from Sony's current planned slate
and again from my money's the Morbius
movie I think at this point it's gonna
take two flops to properly derail this
because since they've had their first
genuine hit unless the sequel come I'll
revise that if the venom sequel bombs
that's gonna throw things off but
assuming that that doesn't happen which
I doubt it will because Sony is pretty
stingy so for my money they are not
gonna grant a ton more money to making
venom 2 then they did the venom one and
and with how strong the the first one
performed I would expect the second one
even if it is not received in general as
well as this one that it will still
it'll still make its money back I have a
hard time imagining a scenario in which
it doesn't so I'm kind of taking that as
a given but you know if the movies movie
flops you know they'll still have had
you know two successes most likely under
their belt up to that point so they'll
try again with something else I think it
takes two serious flops before Sony's
severely reconfigures its plans I think
right now they're just gonna move
forward Bold As Brass with what they've
got on what they've announced so yeah
the the sony spiderman lists
spider-verse
is the thing that's gonna happen oh and
yeah into the spider-verse is another
thing that's happening but I really feel
like that's like completely separate
beast and that being successful will or
flopping will not make or break any of
the live-action stuff so those are sort
of my thoughts on the current status of
Sony slate in other words it's happening
expect most of it to happen at this
point so what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff to do cuz there's
buttons and there's links including a
link to my patreon hey if you feel like
it
check those out there's a bunch of other
links besides that there's cool stuff
give it a look unless you don't feel
like it in which case don't worry about
it because you're the council and I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]